Привет! В прошлый раз мы собрали твою среду. Это был последний шаг модуля и всего курса. Сегодня
я предлагаю на минуту остановиться и посмотреть на весь путь целиком, что мы прошли, что мы теперь
умеем и куда дальше идти. Это финал модуля, а модуль у нас последний, так что по сути это выпуск. Новых
инструментов не будет, просто соберём картину. Начнём с пути. В модуль ты зашёл с накопленной за
курс с заготовкой, данные EPRD, собранная в Figma система, готовый визуал. На входе это всё
ещё было только макетом. Дальше мы шаг за шагом превращали его в рабочий продукт, подняли проект на
реакте, перенесли в код твою дизайн-систему, собрали каталог компонентов, чтобы продукт можно было отдать
разработчикам. Сложили из этой базы экраны и оживили их. Навигация, формы, данные, крайние состояния — всё
это у нас работает. После чего выкатили в сеть, получили живую ссылку, подключили дашборд и научились
снимать поведение на реальных людях, а также проводить новые итерации, сравнивать метрики и тем
самым замкнули цикл права. И в финале собрали всё это в твою собственную ИИ-среду. Если в одну
строку ты прошёл путь от идеи до живого продукта, который открывается по ссылке и до среды, в которой
ты его дальше можешь вести. Теперь самое важное, что ты теперь умеешь сам. Ради этого мы и шли весь
курс. Ты можешь направить агента, собрать рабочий продукт на реальном стеке, в то, что живёт в коде и открывается
по ссылке. Ты держишь связь между фигмой и кодом, поменял в системе, перевыявил, первоисточник
всегда у тебя. Ты можешь передать продукт разработчикам в понятной им форме, ты можешь передать продукт
разработчикам в понятной им форме, каталогам компонентов, репозиториям на гитхабе, можешь выкатить
его в сеть и дать людям ссылку. А также провести юзер-тест, увидеть, где люди спотыкаются и замкнуть
цикл, находка, правка, передиплой, проверка. А также можешь растить под себя среду, в которой все это
происходит и под твой продукт. И что самое приятное, нигде мы не писали код руками. Ты направлял агента и
получал результат. Это та роль, которой мы шли. Дизайнер, который выпускает реальные продукты, понимает,
как они устроены, выполняет роль визионера и при этом остается дизайнером. И тут важный момент
про твой продукт. Все это время ты собирал свой продукт. Тот, что выбрал в начале курса. Поэтому
отдельного итогового проекта как такового не будет. Твоя курсовая по этому модулю и есть итоговый
проект. Это твой продукт, он у тебя уже на руках, живой, открывается по ссылке. И более того, теперь,
когда среда обновлена, дальше идти будет быстрее и удобнее. Можешь дособрать экраны, до которых не дошли
руки, довести то, что откладывал до ума, причесать детали и даже можешь юзер-тест прогнать с
дашбордом. Требовать этого я, конечно, не буду, но инструмент у тебя есть, почему бы этого не сделать?
Среда теперь работает полностью на тебя и под тебя. Куда расти дальше? Первое - это сам продукт и
среда. Они теперь твои и ты их развиваешь. Новые задачи, новые навыки под них, новые куски,
которые агент берет на себя. Чем дольше работаешь, тем плотнее среда подстраивается под тебя, но не забывай
периодически ее чистить и следить за обновлениями в методологии Антропик. Ну, не обязательно
следить, там раз в недельку вызываешь директиву из прошлого урока и она уже не пересобирает заново,
а просто сверяется с актуальной методологией и что-то, возможно, для тебя улучшает. И второе,
что стоит отметить, за тем, что мы делали, стоит еще один слой - инженерный. Собрать продукт ты уже
можешь, но тут есть второе дно. Как собирать автоматизации каких-то клиентских процессов, то есть приема звонков,
общения в мессенджере и так далее. Все это уже другая сторона продукта, инженерная его часть и с
этим нужно разбираться отдельно. Про это я расскажу в следующем уроке. Ну, а пока на этом модуль закрыт,
вместе с ним и курс. Спасибо, что дошел до конца, мы прошли просто огромный путь. Я очень рад сказать,
что ты теперь я и на этим дизайнер. Итоговое задание собирает весь курс по артефакту с каждого
модуля. Прислать нужно в Zen-классе твою проектную документацию из первого модуля, Figma со всеми экранами
из второго модуля, нодовый граф под твой визуал из третьего модуля, живую ссылку на твой дедеплоенный,
докрученный продукт. Все это ты уже собирал, все это ты проходил. А теперь в качестве финального для модуля
задания и итогового по совместительству ты можешь пройти по всему еще раз, закрыть дыры,
которые, возможно, где-то у тебя остались, довести продукт, может быть, вообще до идеала. Тут уже на
свое усмотрение. Ну и самое последнее. Не забудь написать твои впечатления, как тебе курс, что тебе
понравилось, что было тяжело. Я это обязательно прочту. Мне очень важно это от тебя услышать. На этом все.
Поздравляю с прохождением курса. Увидимся на эфирах, возможно, в каких-то новых уроках и в
следующих продуктах. Удачи с выполнением итогового задания. Пока!